remember all confidence starts would be
in courageous courage is jumping out of
the plane and growing wings on the way
down go look in your past at times when
you weren't sure if you go through but
you made it happen when you thought you
wanted the girl and you got the girl so
for 10 years now I've been on a news
diet I don't watch the news I have no
clue what's going on nor do I care
Juanes or get a mentor what's up believe
nation at seven I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so today
let's learn from one of the best dean
grazie OTT and some of his best advice
on how to get super confident mentor me
Dean
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one start with courage what's the best
way you found to build confidence I have
zero and it's holding me back from
meeting new people and everything else I
want to share two quick things first the
first thing I would do is why don't you
make a list right now of ten things that
are cool about you just to make ten
thing it's really difficult no one likes
to talk about themselves or but make a
list of 10 things cool about you and let
them sink in that you've done amazing
things in your life Cory you're just
right now you're only thinking of things
you did wrong you're not thinking of the
things you did right start thinking
about the things you did right and then
the second part remember all confidence
starts with being courageous courage is
jumping out of the plane and growing
wings on the way down courage is taking
a step in a room taking a step towards a
girl taking a step without knowing the
outcome so start with courage the second
is commitment nothing you've ever done
in your life it has worked without being
committed relationships don't work
businesses don't work be committed the
third part is get the capabilities and
once you have courage once you commit
once you have the capabilities then all
of a sudden confidence just starts to
grow confidence comes when you're in the
game
Trenton would have never got confidence
in football if he was always on the
sidelines it was when he was in the game
and he got hit and carried the ball and
did the things he did he found his
confidence there you don't find the game
you don't find confidence being on the
sidelines so courage capabilities that
will lead you to some more confidence
rule number two
borrow confidence from the past I want
you to borrow confidence for the past
you see when we're doing something we
have to muster up the confidence we
think of the things that could go wrong
we think of what if I don't come through
what if I don't say the right things I
need to rehearse this over and over what
if what if what if what if we change
that and instead of thinking about what
could go wrong of course we know this
start thinking about what can go right
but better yet rob confidence from the
past go look in your past at times when
you weren't sure if you go through but
you made it happen when you thought you
wanted the girl and you got the girl or
you got the guy you got the job
you got the deal you got the money you
got the same
a type you you you scored the touchdown
you got the run you were good at banned
you you were the star of the play rob
confidence from the past remind your
body remind your cells remind your
subconscious what it felt like and bring
it into the present time I'm telling you
you can transcend that old confidence
into your current state and watch you
change your state of mind change just
like that rule number three go on a news
diet what are the things that dig in
your confidence I realized at an early
early time has probably been ten years
that watching the news for me when I
watch the news and I see that it looks
like the world is going to hell in a
handbasket or what the president is
saying today or what Congress is saying
or you listen to the left or the right
or there were people in the middle if
you listen to all the gun violence at
all like all the news does for me is
make me question where the world is
going in my next level so for ten years
now I've been on a news diet I don't
watch the news I have no clue what's
going on nor do I care it was the
biggest transformation in my life I
where I want to spend my time I would
spend time with my family the people I
love my kids my team members they
deserve the best of me they don't
deserve Dean at 95% confidence they
deserve a hundred percent and if I watch
the news it brings it down so I won't be
the best team leader I won't be the best
father I won't be the best man I can be
I won't be a best inspiration for you to
screw the news it Digg is my confidence
it's out I've been on a news diet I
challenge you to do the same thing rule
them before get rid of negative people
on your journey you're gonna come across
all new friends you're gonna lose old
friends for a while you're gonna you're
gonna get a people in your life who love
you that try to suppress you and they're
gonna want to hold you back and here's
the thing you have a couple options in
your life you can let them dim your glow
that you can let them turn down your
fire or you can realize it's not their
fault so let me just ask you again I
want to go back to this who in your life
makes you feel bad about your dreams
your goals your desires because those
people are affecting you whether you
realize it or not when you have a desire
for that next level
someone negative someone
to protect you tells you you shouldn't
you can't you might say now I'm not
listening to them but even if 5% of that
rubs off on you then you might make
different choices you might play a
little bit smaller than you need to your
confidence could be crushed just a
little bit more than it needs to be
crushed you know confidence is a weird
thing confidence doesn't go from zero to
a hundred in my eyes confidence if your
confidence is down five percent you're
screwed because you're gonna play small
you're gonna play safe do you think in
today's world you think being good at
something with most of your confidence
is enough do you think being excellent
with a 90 percent of your confidence is
enough hell no you need to be freaking
outstanding you need to rock it with
your confidence at a hundred percent and
how can your confidence be at a hundred
percent if you're letting people in your
life make you dim your glow to lower
your expectations to play safer and rule
number five the last one before a very
special bonus clip is protect your
confidence I have this concept of
protect your confidence I've never heard
anybody say it like that before why is
that so important because I think I mean
in all the big decisions you've had to
make along your way have you ever made a
good decision when your confidence was
down once like can you say I walked in
my head was down your physiologies
change you're like a little nervous like
you just don't make good decisions when
your confidence is down and and I don't
think it's like we're either confident
or not confident I think it's like if
confidence is a hundred percent if our
confidence is ninety five percent we
play smaller I know with me like the big
opportunity's come if I'm not in that
like space I'm like you know what guys
let's just let's hold let's not like I
won't make smart decisions so I think I
think we have to do everything in our
power to protect our confidence so that
that theory of protecting your
confidence has been there's been a major
thing in my head always in fact I have a
you know we all have our own morning
routines not maybe not everybody but I
have a morning routine that I have to do
to get me to play and way I look at is
play offense for the day not play
defense with lower confidence what does
that look like I've tried a lot of
variations and for me it's if I
immediately when I wake up I can't check
my phone in fact I put it on airplane
mode and I move it I got that from
Arianna Huffington who's
amazing and she's like is your phone
still by your bed it's just airplane
mode on the other side of the room you
know so that and then I just know so
many people roll over and grab their
phone and to me that's like Russian
Roulette you put a bullet in the gun and
you spin it it's like what if the email
says the deal didn't happen numbers are
down life's not working out like mamede
Ephraim me it's like you open up and and
this little box is gonna dictate the
first couple hours or maybe the whole
day by what you see so I've just I just
won't look at my phone when I first wake
up so but when I first opened my eyes
this is all and I like doing things
quick for me cuz I want to get to the
gym because the only time of day I'll go
if I try to wait to the afternoon it
doesn't work for me so as soon as I wake
up I immediately try to think of
something I'm grateful for which
everybody knows that and thinks about it
but I've I play this game myself on how
far I can lower the bar meaning I I try
to do a gratitude journal about three
years ago and after about five weeks I
ran out of stuff to say I'm like I
already brought my kids and this and
life like what I put in here I got and
then I was like wow 150,000 people die
every single day you can google it
that's the number it's like some days I
wake up I'm just like I'm here awesome
and I feel that silly little thing like
I'm here or I'm like oh my god the
sheets feel softer than they've ever
felt and I'll literally think that
myself these sheets are really good like
what a third of the world sleeps on the
on a dirt floor and I have sheets in an
amazing bed and look at the view I have
and that's enough just because the way I
know is I'm just just tweaking my brain
enough to be in a grateful place it
doesn't have to be this for me and you
guys might have better practices I'm not
talking about a half hour gratitude
meditation
I just need one little thing or I pick
up a book if I'm reading one of the
books that you have on the shelf
I'll pick and I'll just pick three
sentences and read something empowering
and I'll get that state of mind from my
brain and then I think about one win I
had the day before because I know as
entrepreneurs as somebody searching for
success we never give ourselves credit
we'd never treat a friend the way we
treat ourselves it's like I know I've
had days I've gone till 10 o'clock at
night go man I got nothing done today
the biggest lie like we beat ourselves
up we just were like these racehorses we
wouldn't even treat a racehorse that we
owned as bad as we
our selves right so I wake up and I'll
do a quick little gratitude and they'll
say what was one win yesterday that I
accomplished like wow you didn't do that
yes and then I'll think of one win I
want to do that day like what I'm gonna
need a million things done today but
what's a must today that would be a
great win and then for me then I
immediately go downstairs in my house
and I drink I felt like I fed my my mind
and I want to feed my body so for me
I've been doing the same drink forever I
do apple cider vinegar lemon MCT oil a
scoop of green powder and mix that up
and I downed that and then I immediately
got to go to the gym
now I've got a special bonus clip with
Dean on how to manufacture confidence
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from just watching another video to
taking action in your life for business
and if you're feeling bold leave your
answers in the comments below here we go
question number one what negative people
do you need to let go of number two what
would a news diet for the next week look
like for you and number three what was
your most courageous moment that you
need to remember
think about how many times in your life
you had a massive win because you had no
confidence it doesn't exist right if you
were looking to go meet that girl or
that guy and you walked up me like hey
you know I was hoping we could you
couldn't get you know that doesn't work
you're walking to business meeting hey
do you think we could know that doesn't
work go to talk to your kids about
something in school hey kids
no you need confidence you need the
energy need to be alive well if you know
me and been watching my videos that's me
I've made my career on enthusiasm and
energy and being in the right state of
mind having the confidence but you don't
the biggest myth is that you're born
with confidence no I was the shyest kid
in the world
I felt so insecure felt dumb I learned
how to manufacture the confidence and
after 25 years of being an entrepreneur
generating hundreds of millions of
dollars being blessed to touch the lives
of millions of people around the world
what I know for a fact is that you can
create the state of mind and the
confidence to live the best you to
unlock that inner hero
if you want to see Dean's top ten rules
video that I made the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there and I want to tell you passion and
from the heart always always wins over
over prepared and thinking from the head